bonjour marisa merci d'être en direct
avec monsieur rt france alors le convoi
de la liberté c'est un mouvement né
récemment au canada qui encore tout
nouveau 1 ici en france quelles sont vos
principales revendications sont elles
les mêmes qu'à ottawa
nos revendications c'est bien entendu la
suppression définitive du pass pass
sanitaires tout on ne veut plus vivre
avec d'idée d'avoir un pass c'est bien
entendu également
l' envie de défendre nos enfants
ça fait deux ans qu'ils souffrent et par
toutes les mesures sanitaires qui leur
ont été imposées donc on veut qu'ils
reprennent l'école dans des conditions
optimum pour eux et puis bien entendu
que tout chaque personne ait des moyens
de vie décentes à partir du moment où
ils travaillent ou même qu'il reçoit des
subventions de l'état et récupérer
toutes les droits et libertés que nous
avons perdu depuis deux ans alors ce
sont des revendications qui tourne
surtout autour des restrictions
sanitaires de qui se compose aujourd'hui
ce mouvement en france
de tous les français
y'a pas c'est impossible de nous mettre
dans une case alors on dit gilet jaune
on a entendu aussi extrême droite bah en
fait non c'est sûr que ça arrangerait
tout le monde de nous mettre dans ces
petites cases puisque ça voudrait dire
qu'on est juste des extrémistes mais
c'est pas ça c'est chaque citoyen ça va
de l'ouvrier au médecin toutes ces
personnes dont moi nous sommes nous en
avons assez de cette situation et c'est
pour ça que nous nous convergeons vers
bruxelles alors bloqué paris par les
routes c'est toujours l'objectif affiché
du mouvement
alors ça ne l'a jamais été pour qu'on
veuille france
c'est une convergence sur bruxelles et
bien entendu il fallait bien que nous
réunissions un endroit en france donc
c'est la capitale qui a été choisi mais
comme nous l'avons dit depuis le début
que nous resterons en région parisienne
nous n'entrerons pas dans la capitale
nous ne souhaitons pas la bloquer c'est
juste on veut se retrouver ça fait deux
ans qu'on nous les parcs on y re
distancie donc nous avons besoin de
recréer cette solidarité et ensuite nous
convergeront sur bruxelles bruxelles où
les autorités ont également interdit le
rassemblement alors qu'est ce que vous
prévoyez comment ça va se passer
pour l'instant c'est en pleine réflexion
avouerai que les autres les autres états
de l'europe on va de toute façon elle
est sur la belgique on verra bien sur
place comment ça va s'organiser en tant
que tel est ce que ce mouvement est
amenée à s'installer dans le temps selon
vous donc là pour l'instant c'est à
court terme puisque vous nous parler de
la belgique mais si jamais vous n'êtes
pas entendu par les gouvernements est-ce
que vous avez déjà une idée des actions
que vous comptez mener
alors il ya une idée claire
c'est celle de dire qu'on reprendra le
pouvoir mais de façon démocratique c'est
à dire que dans très peu de temps pour
la france ce sont les élections et il ya
des élections législatives bien si c'est
ça on comptera des listes citoyenne et
puis on prendra entre ça sera nous les
députés demain merci beaucoup maryse à
avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes porte-parole de a
convoyé france